hey little guys my name is Jenna welcome
back to my game engine series so last
time we took a look at just some
maintenance talk and some of the stuff
that we kind of wanted to get done
before we started heavy-duty kind of
full statement head work on the renderer
especially because I'm getting married
next week and I'm just not gonna have
time at all I kind of wanted to shift
the beginning of the renderer to kind of
after I get married so that I can just
be like bam bam bam episode episode
episode 1 so we can get a lot done
without kind of having this huge gap so
because this is stuff that we need to
clean up anyway and because I've made
some changes after talking about this
with you guys I just figured that it
would be a really good spot for us to
just get this done so that then later we
don't have to come back and be like our
before we before we can continue we
should change this or it'll be harder to
change it in the future let's get
everything done right now I think that's
the best plan even though I know that it
is annoying for some that we just can't
wait to start the renderer believe me
I'm one of those people I rent lit
renderings my favorite part of this
whole engine anyway so I really want to
be able to start that but we have to get
this stuff done so today what we're
going to do is we're going to convert
hazel to be a static library and we're
also going to clean up all of our kind
of build projects I guess and I think
there are some some issues with the
repository as well because if you do
like a clean check out of hazel I think
for example it doesn't include pre make
the pretty bit premake exe file or
something like that I'm not sure exactly
what happens but we'll take a look at
this kind of stuff I just want to get
everything done so that we have those
pre make files clean and as they're
meant to be without anything extra I
think we if we the goal really is to
reduce the warnings we have right now
now kind of repository just zero when we
build this stuff we should have zero
warning it's hopefully by the end of
this video I don't think it'll take too
long at all and then the other major
thing of course is just converting hazel
to be a static library instead of a
dynamic library because we talked about
that last time he's just gonna be pretty
easy to do
and it's just gonna simplify the
development so much and as I discussed
in the previous episode I don't think
hazel needs to be a dynamic library so
because we've kind of lost that use case
after some more design work went in I
think that it's just gonna simplify over
everybody's lives and just
and an internal result in a more
optimized application if hazel actually
builds as a static library and then
links into the game that's not to say by
the way that we can't link modules in as
like dynamically in the future that's
totally possible like what you could do
and what I can explore because I know
that this was like one of those things
excuse me one of those things that
people kind of brought up were I like
kind of in its software's design unlike
the doom engine or everything kinda had
the game as a DLL that hooks into the
engine the engine kind of runs that DLL
I like that design maybe we knew
something like that um I don't want you
for simplicity's sake of because I don't
think we need it to be honest but what I
won't all-out and what we definitely can
do in the future is actually dynamically
load a modular DLL which can contain say
plus plus code that will actually be
executed as part of that game or
anything like that that's pretty easy to
do and we can still set up do a little
hot swapping if we wanted to all of that
will just work so that's definitely
something that we can do this design
moving to a static library does not rule
out all dll's for the future it just
means that the core hazel library will
be built as a static library and has to
be statically linked into our actual
application Exe file so that's the only
real thing that's changing let's jump in
and take a look at how we can do that
and just in general the state of this
solution okay so what I'm gonna do right
now is just clean this whole solution
and just give it a build I reverted all
of the stuff that we did last episode
you can see straight away that we have
warnings like unknown ignoring on an
option and the c11 kind of STD and also
there's linking the studio 32 leave I
don't even know where that came from to
be honest like we wrote it in the
Premack but I don't know why we have a
lot of these warnings which is just kind
of DLL interface has to be used and it
needs to have a DLL under has to be used
and this is from like um shed pointers
and said essentially just because
they're like template classes and that
is causing an issue across DLL
boundaries that'll be resolved because
we're moving to a static library what
else is there so we've got these
warnings this stuff needs to be fixed
just by declaring just by using this
macro called CRT secure no warnings
again if it was our code I'd probably
use the secure version of the function
which is
takes in a size for the buffer so that
it doesn't overflow the buffer but
because it's not our code as I'm Louise
code we're gonna obviously trust that
code and say that it's not going to fail
because that's that kind of domain so
we're just gonna enable the right macro
to build that code we should be fine if
we wanted to do that by the way but keep
in mind there are easy ways to fix this
right let's take a look at what we'll
take a look at these errors probably at
the end because they're really simple
but um I know that a lot of you might be
like and I just really want to move this
over as much as possible so you guys can
actually see but a lot of you might be
like well you know why this whole use
this whole CIT secure no warnings thing
like why just because I'm GUI has that
why do we have to enable that for our
entire hazel project and I think as we
don't right if you take a look at this
this file this causing this is this I'm
GUI in pull up in jail three LC file
that's coming that's being built from
I'm glue build aa CPP because that's how
kind of unity build file for for certain
I'm gooey stuff we can just define that
macro there right and that'll be fine we
don't have to define it in the project
settings in our pre make settings or
anything like that we can just define it
just there right just in that file and
then that way the rest of hazel will
still kind of have to was to receive
warnings if we use deprecated functions
so don't worry too much about that um
anyway I think that's probably all the
different ones right now and when we
have some kind of like we have some
runtime conflicts as well like you know
these linking warnings why this default
Lib just conflicts with use of auto lips
that's because deal these different dll
files or static libraries essentially
end up using different versions of the
runtime library which I think should be
resolved once we switch to static
linking anyway how do we switch to
static linking well the magic and all of
the code really is inside our pre make
files what I'm gonna do here just to
make things really really easy is just
search for all probably all lower files
or just all pre make files doesn't
matter and once I've got all of these
I'm just gonna open them with vs code
okay so now we've got these open when
it's done kind of sort through these so
we have jelf w the glaad one the hazel
one and the i'm doing one just gonna put
the hazel one first because it should be
first let's take a look at what we have
here so currently hazel builds as a
shared library we just need to change
to say static library and technically
speaking that is it it's now a static
library dawn right now because we're
linking it as a static library we should
link static runtime we should link the
runtime library statically as well okay
so I'll just turn that on okay what that
means is that essentially when we build
our executable it will link in its own
runtime library and that'll be it the
reason we didn't want to have this for
dynamic libraries is because if we're
linking dynamically a dll file needs to
have it actually needs to have the
runtime library linked in because the
dll files can like a final product and
so because of that if we link statically
it means at Build time every dll that we
build could theoretically have different
versions of the library and that is a
huge issue like some might have symbols
on or extra tape because some might not
that's a huge problem if you allocate
memory with the debug version of the
runtime library and and free it with the
release version that will crash your
program if not caused massive like
memory corruption because they allocate
memory differently so problems like that
can arise but if we link if this is a
static library we can link everything
statically and everything should be fine
this kind of stuff signals was dialect
that doesn't need to be a window
specific thing really so I'll put it on
the language so we'll have kind of
location kind language and then language
and dialect we'll put together and then
static on time on so system version
latest is the other thing we have kind
of under windows apart from defines this
post build command no longer needs to
exist because we're not copying dll
files after building anymore and the
next step is gonna be kind of is all of
our configuration so debug release and
dist
so this stuff is gonna say pretty much
the same I'm just gonna make these
lowercase because they don't need to be
uppercase just to stick with what
Premack actually recommends you do in
their dog's butt so symbols on meaning
this will be the debug version of the
library this is kind of the same thing I
think we had or maybe I'm wrong but I
think yeah we had this kind of stuff
right which just means like a link link
the multi-threaded like the link the
version of the library that is that
doesn't have debug symbols on it right
now that's why we did that for at least
we don't need that though because
technical look at this mess and what
about a fixes stuff
we don't need that because if you write
optimize on that's a release version of
the library of your eyes symbols on
that's the debug version okay of the
runtime library so that's essentially
what ends up getting linked so we have
this this looks great
and although of course we've got runtime
realities as well but symbols on and all
of that just means that we're gonna
generate debug symbols whereas here
we're gonna optimize that code all right
so that's fine runtime defines that as
well so runtimes specifically meaning
the C++ standard runtime of course in
case that's not clear sandbox at a
ground time on and we're going to again
move super typically dialect up here so
we have that there
this stuff looks pretty good to me we
obviously don't need any kind of jela
copying which we don't have anyway and
everything else looks good I might just
make these lower case as we did before
that should be it for actual hater right
done yeah that looks good to me that's
all we need let's move on to the jail of
w1 so um we're building a static library
of course the language is safe with me
any kind of CBP dialect things these the
files were including and then for
Windows we don't need these flags at all
they don't do anything anyway as we saw
when we build stuff this inversion
should be set to latest and static rock
time should be set to on interesting
that that was on because that trigger
probably been off earlier but anyway we
have files we have defined specific to
Windows under here and then again for
this stuff we really don't need this
what we do need to do is go back into
here and make sure that we essentially
grab these things I think that gfw only
has release and debug so we just need to
make sure that we will get rid of dist
but just make sure that we basically
just have the right version of the right
time and the right symbols actually set
up for debug and release so that we do
have debug symbols on for debug and
optimization all for release with no
debug symbols that's cool
it's also quite common to have a mix of
these by the way where you might have
optimizations on but you still keep
symbols but what I'm gonna worry about
kind of advanced configurations like
that at the moment I'm stuck on time on
as well we're gonna pull this up because
there should be on not just for Windows
but for everything okay that looks good
to me
one thing I might do is just view the
white space here just because I want to
I think is this just because I want to
make sure that everything yeah you see
how we have spaces here and then we have
tabs here I just want to make sure that
we actually have the right thing yeah
because if not it can look weird on
certain text editors and also align I'll
be weird so I'm just gonna make sure
that we have the same the same kind of
whitespace everywhere it looks like
we're using oh great so we're using
spaces here in tabs here we probably
should you two spaces everywhere I feel
I mean by the way I prefer tabs but yeah
okay it doesn't matter as long as we're
using the same across the file that's
really all the matters so we have tabs
here and space in the old one sure
whatever I'm not gonna worry about that
now
all right next one glad so again see how
we have this mix I'm just gonna get rid
of that mix because I wanna serve one
two three four one two three four just
put that there
okay cool now that's good so this is
fine again we don't need this all I'm
gonna make sure is that you know static
runtime we have over here and that's set
to on and then let's see what else do we
need we need to make sure that we copy
this kind of stuff as well so for debug
and release same kind of setup as before
I'll just live leave one extra line
there with no spacing just like I should
everywhere just at the end of every file
cool and I think that's it
well I guess we'll see and then the last
ones I'm GUI
this actually is in the I mean all of
them I think it technically in the
sub-module so I'll have to update the
sub modules as well like I'll have to
push this code to the sub modules which
is fine that looks good and again you
know we'll do
same kind of thing as we did before CBP
dialect in this case goes up here so
does the fact that wearing a well inking
statically static runtime on of course
this builds a static library like it
should and again this this stuff will
just be replaced by what we have here I
don't even know where I got the old code
to be completely honest with you guys I
think maybe I just found it somewhere
online and just copied and pasted
because not really sure why all of it's
so different than everything else to
write okay cool um I think that's all we
need
I might be wrong but who knows okay so
this was good to me right now
um what I'm gonna do now is just kind of
run
how'bout generate projects file so here
we go no era is great and if we go back
to visual studio and just reload all we
should see hopefully everything now set
up as static so if I look at hazel now
it should have the configuration type
static library again I'm just gonna
clean everything and because I want to
do like an ultra clean as I call it um
I'm just gonna delete being and bin in
directories completely okay so now let's
build our solution and see what happens
okay so everything looks pretty good to
me
now obviously what the other big thing
we need to do is actually to stop all of
this stuff locally defined symbols being
imported and all of this all this stuff
is actually just to going to our
revenues this hazel or just a
application core you just go to our
quarter age file which push it because
something like a base but anyway I think
that's what it's called in the
development branch this hazel build dll
we're still exporting and importing
right we shouldn't be okay so
technically speaking what I what I can
do is just write again as a hack or
whatever I can just hide this behind you
know H said
dynamic link and say if that's the case
than that otherwise we can just define
hazel API as not
all right that's kind of the idea so
define hazel API alright so that way
this gets to fine is nothing which means
that if we look at literally any any
class here this is just nothing which
means it kind of is just that right so
that's kind of the idea now obviously if
we never ever ever want to have dynamic
linking ever then we should just remove
hazel API completely and then everything
will just be too flat like this and
that's probably something we will do in
the future
I just don't waste time right now like
assertion replace everything I mean it's
not going to be too difficult you guys
want to do this you can just do hazel
API space and replace that with
literally nothing and that will just
clear all the hazel api's that should
work generally well I don't think I mean
apart from maybe here you'll have to do
additional work but everywhere else that
should just work but what I'm going to
do is just again just clean a solution
after this and build everything ok look
at that so this looks a lot cleaner now
because we don't have those errors about
the dll interface stuff um and we don't
have there's warnings a certain my
errors warnings but we also don't have
the warnings from you know the wrong
kind of command line options being used
which is great so the only warnings we
have left and we can look at the error
list and to make sure oh well there's
this one inside I'm GUI layer where we
convert from one sign into flow so we
can just add a little float cast here
fix that up let's do another build there
you go we might have to rebuild I might
just have to rebuild sandbox so we get
those original warnings back okay there
we go so now we've only got three
warnings left and this stuff what we
could do is we just need to again have
this macro I'm not sure if you guys can
see it all the way off the screen there
but basically this file is using
functions like these not the underscore
task kind of secure version and because
of that they're deprecated and because
of that it's generating a warning what
we could do is of course to kind of fix
that we could go back into our pre make
files and make sure that hazel and
defines where our defines I mean we
don't have any defines
Vox we don't have any defines I think
for all platforms it looks like we've
only got to find some windows but in the
old platforms one we'd have to basically
add CRT secure no warnings we could do
that that's one solution but since I do
want to kind of enforce that we don't
have deprecated functions everywhere
else I mean we still might we'll see
because to be honest I don't really use
the secure version the secure version is
much actually use the non ones but maybe
going forward we'll try and use the
secure ones because of that I can just
take a look at where this files being
built from which is I'm GUI bill built
dot cpp because it's like our little
unity built that's a VP file the ongoing
one isn't being built separately like by
itself I mean it's not being fed into
the compiler if we go into I'm GUI
builders if it babe I can just define
that here right and then that will
obviously only apply this define for
this translation Union after this code
it kind of gets pasted in so that way
you know when not kind of deprecating it
everywhere right
Oh rather we're not allowing this code
everywhere just in this file
we're just suppressing the warning there
so I'll do a rebuild of everything now
and hopefully we should get no warnings
okay so somehow we still actually get
them that's interesting we definitely
shouldn't the other thing I can think of
is maybe the functions that are
including them are probably coming in
here so we might have to just drag that
up before our PCH file let's give that
another build but of course if we do
that we can't do that because it's
precompiled header which i forgot about
so this is actually turning into a
little bit a little bit more of a
problem that I I would hoped it would be
so I mean it defines it here it's
supposedly supposed to define it here if
you actually look at the source code but
it doesn't in this case because we've
got it defined
so actually we shouldn't even need it
technically speaking because he now is
being defined however it's still causing
problems and I suspect that's because
our precompiled header is already
including the stuff that that it
shouldn't be or I'll is it so it's
already including functions that have
that because you can see this
declaration is actually inside its
string dot H which of course is being
included before like it's being included
inside our precompiled header so
technically speaking again if I go to a
jet PCH and before string or whatever I
define that that should actually take
effect here or maybe we'll have to
define it even before that I don't think
iostream to find that stuff um that's a
little bit weird but if we look at this
yeah there we go so I'm Gould actually
builds there and we don't have anything
but unfortunately that's kind of the
same like we disable it everywhere not
just where it's used which is a little
bit annoying I thought that maybe a yeah
obviously it makes sense that it would
it will disable it everywhere
either everywhere not not based on usage
because obviously the deprecation
flag the the compiler attribute for
deprecation is actually there when the
function itself is compiled it's not
used like based on templates or anything
like that like it might be anyway so we
either have it there or I guess the
correct thing to do in this case would
actually in fact to go to my first to do
what I did in my first kind of solution
and that's just to add a define here for
all platforms where we just do statistic
you honor warnings so there we go and
I'll just make sure yeah we've got tabs
everywhere good and now if we just
regenerate projects go back here reload
everything I'll clean again and do it
build we should have zero warnings
finally and we this now would probably
be a good time to turn to turn on
warnings as errors or something like
that if we really want to keep this
building tightly but I probably won't do
that because that might get annoying
okay there we go everything's exceeded
no warnings no errors nothing like that
wonderful nice and clean and if we
launch it everything of course should
work and there we have it okay so that
is pretty much it all right so that's
pretty much it if you guys enjoyed the
video please hit the like button also a
huge thank you to all the patrons that
make this series possible I'm gonna be
away for like the next I don't know two
to three weeks we'll see hopefully I
should have time to maybe make a video
next week because I've taken the week
off work so maybe if the wedding stuff
doesn't
get too much in the way which obviously
it might and obviously I'll prioritize
that I don't want to promise anything
but I might make a video for two weeks
from now we'll see but apart from that
I'm gonna be away for a few weeks so if
you do want to kind of if you don't want
to just let this sit here then the if
your supporters on patreon you can get
access to the development branch which
has a lot of this kind of render of
stuff already done so if you wanna kind
of jump ahead or if you're kind of doing
stuff on your own but you want to see
how I do it we wanted to save kind of
you've done it the correct way or how
we're intending to do it then you can
definitely check that out and also it'll
really help support series which is
great I can't wait to be back for you
guys
and we can finally get onto the render
of stuff so yes hope you guys enjoyed
this video I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]